بلدي حاد
ومن النادر أن تضع وسائل الراحة الخاصة بي مع أطفالي
على أطفال الجميع وأطفالهم وعدم الانتظار حتى
المهم أن العم السنوار يقرر ما يريده
وسيتذكرون أن هناك مختطفين ممن اختطفوا حياة موجودة
لديهم قصة أنهم يمرون حاليًا بقناع o
كثير أو البعض يسيء إلى الوضع أسيرًا
في أصعب الظروف وتحتاج إلى العودة
لهم الآن الشيء هو في الحقيقة تهديد وجودي ل
ودولة إسرائيل ليست أقل من ذلك عندما يقول عاموس
لحظة الأمن القومي لإعطاء علامات التهديد
حماس صعبة كما هي، وبالتأكيد في طريقها
الواحد الذي سنهدم حدود قدراته العسكرية
فهو لا يشكل تهديدا وجوديا لدولة إسرائيل، بل هو جزيرة
عودة المختطفين تهديد وجودي للدولة
إسرائيل لأنه عندما أنت وأنا لا نؤمن بقيادتنا
لن نؤمن بقدرتنا على العيش هنا بأمان أو
لن نكون هنا بالصدفة، لن نكون هنا بالصدفة
أنت تعلم أن ما هو أسوأ سيكون صعبًا للغاية
لخدمة البلاد والمضي قدما، وبالتالي فقد
أعظم أهمية ممكنة تمس حقا
في وجودنا بأنفسنا وبالتالي يجب على المرء أن يستمر
وابذل قصارى جهدك للوصول إلى استمرار الأخبار الجيدة
كلمة صفقة ولكن للوصول إلى النقطة التي نتركها
نجح المختطفون من خلال اتفاق أو آخر
لإنقاذ مختطف واحد عالم وكامل ومتفق
لقد تمكنا من الحصول على 110 مما يعني أننا نعرف
وأنه لا بد من الاتفاق على إعادة المختطف حياً
بنسب عالية جدا، علشان كده بقول عن
رأيي هو أنني مستعد حتى لصفقة صغيرة
أريد أن أبدأ العملية واتركها
آلية عودة الرهائن أريدها
الآن حتى لو قالوا لي أنهم يعودون ثلاثة
أربعة أو خمسة سيصلون في النهاية إلى وادي يوسي أيضًا
لنا أريدهم أن يبدأوا العملية وذلك
ستبدأ هذه الآلية بالعمل فهي ضرورية جداً
تم التعرف على ثلاثة ماروفي عن طريق الخطأ من قبل قوات الجيش الإسرائيلي
كعدو، تم إطلاق النار عليهم حتى الموت بالكامل داخل القطاع
حوادث مأساوية، ليس هناك طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك
كان من الممكن أن ينتهي الأمر بشكل مختلف وكنا جميعا جالسين
نحن هنا نتحدث عن ثلاثة مختطفين نجحوا
للهروب من الإرهابيين أو كما قال جيري ربما
لقد تم التخلي عنهم وعادوا إلى أراضي الأرض وفي هذا المكان الإنجيل
في هذه الحقيقة الرهيبة، تم اختطاف ثلاثة بالفعل
تمكنا من الإنقاذ بطريقة لا نعرف ما هي
هي وأنا لسنا متأكدين أيضًا، سأعرف لأنهم قتلوا وهم
قُتل بالخطأ برصاص ثلاثة مقاتلين من جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
وينبغي القول أن هذه هي المنطقة الأكثر توتراً في القطاع
غزة هي الأكثر والأكثر توتراً والأكثر حياً
متوترة وأيضا الأكثر صعوبة في القتال بالتأكيد في الأسبوع
الأخير هو ساجيا، وهو ليس بعيدًا عن النقطة التي يوجد فيها
كان هذا الأسبوع أسوأ حادث للكتيبة 13
الحرب والحرب
هناك سهلات وهناك أخطاء جسيمة ونكاد لا نكون كذلك
أذكر ولكن الرقم قرأت على الأقل
في صحيفة هآرتس حوالي 13 جنديًا أي ما يقرب من 10٪
من شهدائنا في جنود الكلاب الذين قتلوا نتيجة لذلك
ومن الواضح أنه مع تقدم الحملة، هناك
لقد تحدث الإرهاق ونير بحق عن ضغوط عملياتية هائلة
إذن هناك أخطاء وهناك مواطن الخلل، وهذا واضح بالنسبة لي بالمناسبة
ولن يكونوا مسلحين إذا كانوا مسلحين
سيشير المتحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي إلى أنني لن أدخل
إلى التحقيق والرجل لم يأت ليلوم لا سمح الله
عن الجنود الذين يعملون في واقع مجنون 70
في أوقات التوتر والخوف، لا يمكن المطالبة بالجنود
سقوطهم يقع أصدقاؤهم بعد ذلك
ولسوء الحظ، فإن جميع المختطفين الذين تمكنا من الوصول إليهم كانوا كذلك
الوفيات في هذه الحالة هي الحالة المأساوية بشكل خاص
أنه يمكننا بالفعل إنقاذ أو أخذ الرهائن الأحياء
ونستقبل المختطفين الذين قتلناهم
اسمع هذه هي المآسي الحقيقية الحساسة
تبدو الحرب بهذا الشكل للبطل حدثًا مأساويًا
إنه أمر صعب للغاية من السيناريوهات السوداء التي أردتها
يضعنا جميعا في أذهاننا ما قد يحدث لمسعد
ثانياً، لا نعرف التفاصيل بعد وهذا غير مسموح به
بالنسبة لنا للحكم، أعتقد أن هذه الحادثة توضيحية
قليلا لك
التعقيد الهائل الذي تعمل فيه قواتنا
الأزقة التي في أماكن أخرى كثيفة إطلاق النار
الهائل الذي يواجهونه من التحيزات والاحتيال
حماس بتسجيلات لأصوات بكاء ونحوها
وهكذا وكل هذا تحت النار على ما أعتقد المنطقة
منطقة القتال معقدة وعلينا أن نعطي
الفرصة للقوات وسوف يستجوبون أنفسهم
منطقة لا تزال في حالة قتال نشط وعلى الرغم من ذلك
ويمكن الافتراض أن هؤلاء المختطفين الثلاثة لم يفعلوا ذلك
جرب عليهم وسيلة ما، سميتها أداة
قبلة نعم لهؤلاء الناس لذلك فهو حدث حقًا
رهيب واليوم لا توجد كلمة أخرى لتعريفه بعد ذلك
ولم نحصل على الكثير من التفاصيل حول موضوع التحقيق
لقد حدث الأمر هناك وربما لم ينته بعد
لأنه بالمناسبة أطلقت القوة التي شاركت في هذا الحادث النار
واصل ليتوفيم من هناك بالفعل إلى اضمحلال آخر معه
كابلات متر بجانبها يعني منطقة جدا
نشيط للغاية مع الكثير من القتال ولكنه في الحقيقة كذلك
أنا فقط حزين لأنه اصطدام بين اثنين
أهداف الحرب، أي